the latest figures from public health
england show another jump in cases of
the
indian variant here in the uk in the
last week there have been another
55 people identified as having the
mutated version of the virus which is
known scientifically as b1617 that
brings the total to 132
but government scientists believe there
are more going undetected
now 94 of those have been passengers
entering the uk or their immediate
contacts
but significantly three cases have no
travel history another 22 are still
being investigated
that shows the old travel rules
requiring self-isolation at home
didn't contain the virus and has begun
to spread within the uk
the first known case was identified on
march the 11th
and they've been rising steadily ever
since there have been eight reported
cases in wales
and five in scotland but the majority
119
have been in england with london the
hotspot accounting for 55 of the cases
the virus is a concern because it's
evolved two significant mutations
that may make it more infectious and
help it evade the immune system
it's still not known how well the
vaccines work against the variant
but separate research does show the
vaccines are highly effective against
the more common strains of the virus
after one dose symptomatic infections
fell by 74
they're the ones that can lead to
serious disease and death silent
infections though which have no
symptoms only fell by 57 that's a worry
because
people can spread the virus without
knowing even after vaccination
but scientists advising the government
say vaccines are working so well
and people are generally still cautious
about mixing widely
that cases should fall to low levels in
may and could even
allow people to go without masks over
the summer before rising later in the
autumn
that assumes the variants remain under
control
if they spread they could put back our
attempts to return to a normal life